and those are some major challenges but
there are also other major challenges
that go with stem such as global warming
such as what which Julie will tell it
with me there there's things like global
warming diseases viruses challenges like
that which basis and these are very
difficult problems that in principle
science has told us how to solve a lot
of them but they remain difficult and so
when we're faced with all these problems
like people inhale our world why would
we not want another world another
official world a world made artificial
atoms but these are not the kind of
artificial atoms that you would use in
brewing your coffee or in baking your
doughnut no these are the kind of
artificial atoms you would use for
solving problems impossible intractable
problems and so I'm here to bring you a
homegrown a local flavor a Yale brewed
flavor of how to build artificial atoms
to solve intractable problems but before
I can continue just to demonstrate maybe
I can ask for a volunteer someone who's
not afraid of getting sick I think item
in the back
well he is in the back so come on up I
take it he doesn't need an introduction
so Mike Mike Mike thank you might stem
think we're there yeah everybody say
hello to Mike what energy I want to hear
it again say hello to Mike all right and
hurry like Mike cuz everyone seems to
know him and like it was quite a popular
guy oh he's an RA he's an RA all right
well Mike is mike is healthy now but
imagine imagined it all of the sudden
Mike's bloodstream is struck his truck
down lighters blya wishes will relations
will know us abominations bio virus and
it fell down to the ground bill and no
one is coming to us help what can we do
no Mike how can we help you what is the
what can we do we need a we need we need
something that could save it what do we
do we need a chemically stable cup which
will save my some non-physical i love it
oh Eddie this is virus buyers that has
never been seen by people before and
it's come out it's come out into Mike's
bloodstream and we have no idea what to
do we know how to solve the problem in
principle we know the laws of nature
technically we could compute the stable
compound that will obliterate this
abomination the problem is so hard but
not that it would take longer than the
edge of the universe to compute thank
you Mike you can be healthy again
and so it is impossible problems like
this that require an artificial world
which can solve things that would take
longer than the age of the universe
problems such as that and so might I ask
what is that problem so difficult what
makes it it would say that it is our
world set up by the fundamental building
blocks the atoms which constrain us
which makes some problems difficult and
some problems easy but imagine we can
take those laws and scrap them when we
can build our own laws we can design our
own world the world from artificial
atoms with our laws in which we can make
problems which are difficult here easy
there so we can take difficult problems
and we can step into this other world we
can sell them and bring back the happy
answers and then we can take those
answers back and what might that world
be I believe I believe it is the world
of quantum mechanics the world it is the
world traditionally accessed by Adams
the problem is there are only 116 atoms
there no more they come with fixed
quantum electrical properties and you
just can't make any other ones so if we
want to build an artificial world we
need artificial atoms that we can
engineer so what do you do well you have
a big one asked a very smart man last
year's Nobel laureate David J weinland
oh I had the chance to go and take this
highly embarrassing photo which because
he was look happy at all to see me it's
like who are you get out but he had an
answer a see a sea of electrons now what
might that mean you see at antum sour
electrons so scroll adams throw them out
the window the electrons is all you need
to build the artificial world but it's
not so easy there's a problem and the
problem is
but Adam that electrons are so small if
you've ever looked for an atom you know
it's small look for an electron it's so
instead of using one we use a billion a
billion electrons and billion quantum
electrons however electrons like fish
squid people get agitated when it's hot
at room temperature they're all the Kwan
fish electrons are agitated they're
running around and bumping into each
other and so our electrons represent one
large classical incoherent macroscopic
object but now imagine that we can make
this quantum fish electrons swim
together in unison happy if they can do
that then since all the little
individual fishes are quantum then the
entire school of quantum fish is quantum
but if there is one in a billion that
swims the wrong direction then he then
that little quantum fish will destroy
the quantum miss of the entire school of
fish there will be a green lurking
monster that will eat that coherence and
suck it away in your left with a
classical object and so happy trick them
into loving each other because electrons
they hate each other they repel like
crazy you do a trick you do with
penguins you freeze them you take them
to negative 273.15 Celsius and you
better believe that just like that
Wednesday will be loved each other they
come together hug and move collectively
because it is energetically favorable
old
and so when we when we cool so to just
to recap real quick we can build an
artificial world from the world of
quantum mechanics to harness its
powerful and bizarre laws its nature but
we can't use have to use and set our a
quantum fish electrons but to make them
we will have to take them take a billion
of them and make very very very cool and
so what my help would like because like
all fish our quantum fish electrons
require a home a place to call their own
you can imagine that you take a look
wafer and you slap some atoms on it
because atoms are will again trap
electrons and you arrange them in some
pattern and in fact if if we go in and
zoom into that picture our little fish
aquarium if you will then you will see
that there are only two types of atoms
tilt ones might be aluminum and these
red colored one which would be oxygen
and that is all we use here at Yale that
is all they app to build our quantum
fish aquarium up our little quantum
fishes and a picture of a device might
look something like little blob a ring
but yep billion Adam trap a billion a
billion electrons inside and these
little in this this little blob here
represents our quantum fish aquarium
where our school of fish can live and be
cool so they can swim around like that
and as we call them to negative 273.15
cells yes a just like anyone's they get
fro they get so cold that they come
together hug and move coherently and
that way we can engineer the quantum
electrical property of this little
circuit to mimic the actual behavior of
real atoms except this time they're not
only hundred sixteen we've made the ones
we want and to build a artificial world
from these little individual artificial
atoms all we have to do is make
something like a circuit you take one of
those and you put it here take another
one you put it here a third one here
wire them up boom voilà yeah where you
could step into and hope to compute your
problems solve those kind
problems but what else could we use this
for if we could build quantum computer
like that well imagine there's a very
evil just put some very bad and
information on this computer but he's
hit on it he's encrypted it he's locked
it up with a key and that key just like
your credit card information going over
the Internet is very very long maybe 256
bits so that kind of key has so many
possibilities so many keys to try that
it would take longer than the age of the
universe but imagine that we can
construct the world an artificial world
where you can try all of the keys
simultaneously at once and that's what
we try that's what we're building here
you can try all the keys at once so in
less than a second you can get the right
key the right answer and and break into
this computer and so just to sum it up
problems don't have to be impossible
problems are only impossible if we can
strain our to our world to our laws but
if we can engineer an artificial world
from artificial Adam built up from
billions of called quantum fish
electrons then we can build an
artificial world in which we can step
and do the impossible computations and
with that I'd like to thank you and ask
for questions
yeah try to solve that encrypted message
yeah so the question is how would the
artificial world try to solve the
cracking problem if you will well so
there's the thing is we're all built up
of these atoms right our constituent
matter but because there's so many of
them and there because there's so many
of them you get groupthink so the
individual beauty the individual
behavior and character of those
individual atoms we never observe so
atoms they can do funny things they can
be we've heard this they can be in two
places at the same time they don't have
identity they can't be in the thing
called superposition they can be
multiple places they can teleport things
like that things that we can never
experience as we live in this other
macroscopic world but by tapping into
those other laws that other powerful
side of nature that is there for us that
we can finally access only now into the
21st century and control it is by eating
those kind of behaviors of nature this
fundamental level that we can hope to
plug in if you owe all the keys at once
any more questions yes
Oh
right you have to you have to read out
the answer and that is actually a grand
challenge because this artificial world
has talks in a different way it has
different law so we have to figure out
how to exactly communicate with it and
that is that is a very difficult thing
that we're working out still how do you
measure if you will how do you measure
the result yeah
yes it would be it would be it's an
artificial world in the sense of of the
quantum electrical properties of atoms
so we would it would be a they would
literally be like on a chip it would
have many of them pattern and then you
would have little different channels and
connecting them and you would control
them with different signals something
like that good all right thank you